a grand parade in the capital nepado
armed forces day is a day of pomp and
circumstance for the myanmar military
but for many others the celebrations
mask a brutal reality
these are images from the northern sagin
region
people here say soldiers from the
myanmar military came to their village
in mid-march and set fire to their homes
one soldier said burnt the house and
another said don't burn it i asked them
where i should go if they burn it and
they told me to sleep underneath a mango
tree i had no time to take anything from
my house my whole body was shaking
the junta has previously denied its
troops committed arson
instead it's accused anti-coup opponents
of starting the fires
in yangon the hustle and bustle of city
life has returned
with a few telltale signs of military
rule
anti-junta resistance may not be obvious
but it's there
most people are afraid to speak publicly
there is no institution that we can't
compare them with they are committing
the lowest and most brutal acts acts
that we can't even imagine
the assistance association for political
prisoners says more than a thousand
seven hundred people have been killed by
security forces since the coup
many protesters have fled to jungle
training camps to take up arms against
the military
that is one big miscalculation that the
junta made yeah they misjudged their own
people
thinking that if you
kill many people all the resistance will
die down it has not happened and so it
shows that they don't understand their
own people and they don't know how to
end this present conflict
in his speech on sunday military leader
minong lang vowed to annihilate those
fighting to overthrow military rule
many political analysts say they fear
the crisis and violence in myanmar is
likely to continue
florence louis al jazeera